Dr. Brian Artis's info on the health benefits of nicotine. Yes, I've seen some of his
Instagram videos on this. And he's one of those practitioners that I don't know that he's
practicing any longer. And he says many outlandish things that bother me. And so yeah, I really
struggle with that. I think he was the person that says he's gonna wear a nicotine patch the
rest of his life. But it's the cure all for everything basically. And he's probably selling nicotine
patches. So however, I've also read that these patches can have issues for people with leak he got
at mthfr defects. I'd be taking it for pain with lime. What are your thoughts? It's still a drug. It's
not just pure, you know, organic nicotine from a plant. It's still a drug that you're dealing with.
It still has the chance of having side effects. It still is, you know, there's not been, you know,
full testing on this, you know, not the Jack Dem full testing with, you know, a peer reviewed,
you know, double blind study on everything. That's not what I'm asking for. But it's still what
you're, what you're making claims on Instagram that are that are not necessarily substantiated by
anything. There's just dangers in that that everybody shouldn't be doing this. Everybody should be
doing this. This is a cure all for all this stuff. You know, there's, these people have, you know,
there's maybe backlash from the medical community and these people, but they're so, they have so many
followers, thousands, maybe millions of followers and their videos are getting millions of hits and
they're making a blasted crazy amount of money off of these things. It's really hard to
you trust them. Okay, you look at my Instagram videos. Most of them have maximum length 30 views.
Okay, I don't get any of those views and praise God. I don't. Praise God. Our channel is so small.
And that I would rather take care of a lot less people and do the best possible thing for them than
be making outlandish claims in order just to get hits and just to get views so that we could make
money. We don't monetize any of our channels. So I just think there's a conflict of interests there.
And especially when these people are not licensed to practice anymore, they have no.
There's no danger for them to get in trouble with boards and at the
unprobed boards and pro state government institutional oversight. But we have to have some moral oversight
and some of the things that are being said and done out there and I do think that a lot of things
are the quote unquote alternative community are are just done to get to make outlandish claims to get hits
to get followers to get to sell products when when there's when there's no there's no real data behind
it. So we just have to be careful of that. So that's what I have against Instagram and social media.
You know literally I just basically I'm not making a social media post anymore because it just bothers me
so much of the misuse and abuse out there. And that's just my soap box about some of the stuff.
Let's say a nicotine is bad for everybody. I'm just saying it's not good for everybody. Either none of
this stuff is it's all about balance and this is where I just think it's so important for everybody to have
that a lot of reasons to have a personal relationship with your heavenly father that you could be seeking
asking for wisdom so that you we don't get sucked into things. We all need to be like Lord you just
got to give me your wisdom and teach me your ways so that I don't go down the wrong pathway. Give me
peace about all the decisions that I'm making. That's why I want you to bounce these kind of questions
off of me. So you know it hurts me when I see people I start taking this start taking this start taking
this like whoa you know you get on the Zoom call just talk let's talk about it. I'm not against
all these things but I am against just jumping into it because I saw a video about it. So
should nicotine be beneficial for some people? Yeah maybe can nicotine be negative for some people?
Yes it certainly can be so if you really want me to test you on it I can test you on it at a
cheek swab. If you're going to use it I would test it I would go real slow if you decide that you
feel like you're led to start methylene blue or something else out there that people are making very
outlandish claims where it can be good for people but most of the claims are ridiculous so
but just go slow with it just that's all I would say